bit of a bit of a game show theme kind
of thing here I guess we can down in the
comments what do you think this dice is
for or why would we make these things
look at them all look at them yeah each
thing you make right you got to make a
mold you got to get them made like you
got to be making thousands of them at
once otherwise there's no point of doing
it so why would we bother doing this
what was the point so we'll start out
with these let's give them a good old
roll there so um so yeah what what is
the point of these and why we'll start
off easy some of these are quite obscure
but these ones are hopefully not that
difficult what are these
for I don't know what are they for well
uh I mean you see the numbers on them
well this one says if you look on the
top I guess there isn't a face on the
top but you can still got a number sort
of similar to the ordinary four-sided
die is like just a pyramid and CU it
doesn't have a face on the top you put
numbers either around the base or up at
the tip because you don't have a face
but that's fine you can still pick a
random number by by doing that and so
these are just six-sided dice that are
not the usual Cube but why not there's
like a triangular pyramid on the top so
that's three of your sides and there's
another three on that side it's just
another way to do a sixed die which
isn't a cube cuz you know why stick with
cubes this works as well so there's no
advantage or disadvantage or anything to
this it's just a just a it's just a
different way to do um maybe this an
advanced I don't know is it is it easier
to pick up maybe slightly I don't know
is it more painful to step on
possibly harder to pack harder to pack
that's true they don't act together
nicely and make actually you know what
I've never tried this I don't think they
do yeah there's a gap there that's
that's no good because you know
everybody sticks the usual Cube It's
traditional but what are the other
possibilities there's another way you
can do it what shape is that what is
that name of that shape um I would call
it a bipyramid or triangular bipyramid
well right so the the the thing you need
for the the die to be fair is do we say
die or dice I never figure it out
whatever the thing you need for dice to
be fair is that well all the faces have
to be the same and you know the the
they're sort of all arranged relative to
each other in the same way right so you
can get from any face to any other face
by just sort of rotating it around and
that is true for this shape as well just
as it is for the cube lovely all right
so that's number one all right next one
will be okay what is what is
this
thing so um it looks kind of like a
spinning top again how do I know what
number you've rolled well it isn't super
it's easier in person but I mean I can
see that this is a 20 on the
top and so it's the number that's it's
the number that's on the top right so
that's a two again maybe not the easiest
it's easier when you're when you're in
person and you have like you know depth
perception and stuff like that well and
how many size does it have this side you
can see it's got all of the odd numbers
oh except it doesn't there's a 16 there
all right a lot of odd numbers and
there's a lot of even numbers on that
but there are 20 sides so this is just a
20 sided
die why would you but it's so horrible
right the the the 20-sided die that
people like is the classic the
icosahedron right the the I think some
people would say it's the prettiest of
the Dungeons and Dragons dice why would
you do this well there's a reason which
is that we have I think we talked about
in some previous video the skew D6 it
looks like a ordinary cubicle die but it
is messed up and distorted but still
fair right that's the sort of
mathematical uh point to this is that
you you want to distort it a little bit
but still have it be fair and so there's
the eight-sided fair but distorted and
and the foursided fair but
distorted that one's actually I think an
improvement on the usual four-sided die
because there's a big number on the top
unlike the usual foursided die you get
these like fiddly little things around
anyway and then there's the distorted 12
side of die and the to to round out the
the classic Dungeons and dragon set is a
set seven dice no iOS seed in for you
with a four a six
uh an eight a 12 the two uh 10 Siders
you do percentages and the D20 and the
problem with this so why is this the the
cursed D20 all of the other shapes you
take the standard shape and you distort
it just a little bit and it's still fair
you can still make a fair die out of it
but the D20 the ioss edin that turns out
there's no way to do it there's no way
to like tweak this just a little bit and
have it still be fair it breaks the the
Symmetry we knew we had to do the full
set the full classic scent but there was
just no way to break the D20 and so we
just had to okay we're going to lean
into it just make this horrible horrible
thing the the best you can do is two
10-sided pyramids stuck back to back
that's all you can do so we had to so
you wanted to have a set of dodgy
Dungeons and dragon STS and the only way
you can make a dodgy 20 is to go to this
thing that's what you have to do you
can't tweak it just a little bit doesn't
work that makes sense okay good good for
your like Call of cthulu games where
everything's like eldrich and
weird what's next so these all the same
but uh these we were just talking about
fairness of
dice do these look Fair no they look uh
hard to tell they don't really look
particularly symmetrical right the yeah
I mean the the shapes on the faces are
all
different so this one here 18 that's a
rectangle and 7
is a
triangle and 16 is like a kite shape
they're all different so yeah there's no
reason and actually I have no idea how
fair this is we never tested it for
Rolling because these are not for
Rolling okay what else do people use
dice Force so these are used for keeping
track of your score or your life points
so these are called countdown dice or
some you called spin down dice maybe you
start with 24 Health points and then
you're playing Magic Gathering or
something and then you take some damage
and then you go down to you got 22
Health points you just leave it on there
on the table so you know what you don't
usually countown Dice look something
like this so it's an ioss hedron starts
with 20 because in Magic you have 20 20
life points and then you go down to 19
Health points and 18 and 17 and 16 and
it it follows like you know a nice path
so this is numbered not the way that a
usual diey would be where they're like
all over the place because you want to
find oh what's the next number
and the the the disadvantage of this is
that you've got three different
directions to go which which way do you
go and then there's another weird thing
with this one 13 12 11 where's
10 got 19 on this side and 12 and six 10
is on the complete opposite side because
whoever made this die D decided that
opposite side should still out to 21
even though you're not anyway I don't
know why they did this I mean this is a
very first world problem it must said
but still you know you're trying to find
the next number and you don't know which
way to go whereas uh the the new and
improved version has this nice path that
that winds its way all the way down to
one and then back to
24 the design sort of related to these
things called sphericons which are these
kind of like maybe you've seen these
they like it sort of rolls and it not a
not a polyhedron but there sort of
smooth things where you kind of roll and
it kind of Wiggles back and forth and
this is doing the same sort of thing but
with the kind of uh polygonized version
so that you can you can do the
dice this seems like a bad way to keep
track of your score cuz you could so
easily knock it and then it's like oh
what what number was around true it's
true how stable is your table do you
think we can get it to
go no no it's it seems like the optimal
design would be one that is hard to roll
right right and we did think about that
like you know we wanted to maximize
right the shape is not a standard
polyhedron like it came from somewhere
so we definitely wanted to maximize the
like the Tipping angle right how far do
you need to move the center of gravity
before it will be on the tip so right
you don't want to tip from 14 to 10 like
that you don't want that to be easy so
that's a really sharp angle and then the
other ones we're trying to like make
them as much as you can well and why is
it 24 right why not 20 because there was
a parody thing that you have to had to
work with yeah creating the path that
nice optimal path so you can easily go
from 1 to 24 or 24 to 1 right was that a
trivial mathematical problem or was
there some crunching involved so so
there's a couple of things I mean first
is just what is the sort of the large
scale like how many numbers are going to
be how many times does it wind back and
forth the original sort of idea for this
came from there's a guy called Alexandre
munes and he said can you do just can
you do a sphericon countdown die and the
usual sphericon has these like
two kind of circles and it wobbles back
and forth like this you go up down up
down and then you be back at the start
so there would be like four of these
things we start we said oh that's a cool
idea and then we started playing with it
and then immediately realized wait there
isn't a number on top so somehow the
fact that if you go up and down twice
there's sometimes like a corner on top
or on edge whereas with three times this
is what this does it goes up and down
three times then you always get a face
on
top so that was not obvious initially
and then there was this whole other side
of like well how do you make the shape
how do you decide what the angles are
and that that we used um there's some
like optimization stuff to to do with
the 3D software that I use you can
generate things that change the shape of
stuff and and try to optimize things so
that's what we did nice okay all right
all right next this is
uh oh gosh nice and not not too
complicated this one but it's kind of
fun to play with what we got here so
what are these about so you will notice
that there are not numbers on these
instead there are letters so maybe you
can guess what this is for you're trying
to make a word you're trying to make a
word it's sort of like a you know like a
word game again not so easy to tell
which letter is on top necessarily but
this is CH h o e and Zed um so the Zed
might be a problem uh
what can we do uh the C isn't fantastic
either um he is a twetter word um this
will randomly generate you five letters
generally you five letters yes and then
you're going to try and make the longest
word you can right or or you know I play
some sort of word game with us there's a
bit of a cheat here we gave you a u with
a Q because you know it's kind of
difficult to deal with the queue
otherwise there is something uh
interesting here right
so you a comparison with is with Boggle
right Boggle has you know the grid of of
cubes and when you do that you can you
can like one cube is only going to have
vowels on it so you know you're going to
get some vowels and here we're like okay
we're going to make you know one design
and then they've all got to work for
this so the distribution of the letters
is sort of the interesting part right oh
so they're not there's not 26 on each
there's not 26 sides right there are
well so we went for 60 sides cuz what we
were going for is like okay what can you
do that's the closest to the
distribution of letters in the English
language um so obviously there's going
to be more e and T's then there are
going to be q's and KS and JS and so on
and so we went for 60 because you know
you could do this for 30 you can make a
30 signed die but then you don't have
much wiggle room because you want at
least one of everything and then it's
like all I've got my 26 and I got four
extras okay which is going to be e and t
and like it just isn't going to give you
good distribution so 60 is reasonable we
have done 120 sides but it's a big
expensive D It's kind of diffult to work
with and so this 60 sided thing was the
thing to go for does each of the five
dice have the same distribution yeah
that's one of the things in like the
logistics of doing this is like making
each die you know you're going to you
got to make a mold and if you're going
to have like I mean you could have
different Dice and and you know get the
distribution be better but it would be
more expensive to generate them all for
each one of them and so we all right
well can we do with one what is the
distribution can we put on the screen or
something or um or is that like your
secret I mean it's not that secret cuz
you can just look figure it out so can I
put on the screen what the distribution
is absolutely so there's the
Distribution on the screen so there's um
how did you come up with those numbers
well right there's a bit of an
interesting story there as well so this
is essentially the same problem as
assigning seats in Congress because you
got very small states who you know if
you went purely by the the numbers
wouldn't have any representation at all
you can't have that so you need to add
one here and take away one here so who
loses out and who gains so obvious ly
the J's and the q's and the Zeds they
need to have a bit of help CU otherwise
you would't get any and that's why we
got a zed now right right yeah so it
makes it more difficult and then you
have to take it away from somebody's how
do you do it you can say okay you have
to round down to get this letter its
number so it deserves more so we'll take
away one from it or you know you can
figure yourself out like that when you
were deciding when you were making these
decisions did you do it purely
mathematically or was there a bit of did
you put a bit of thumb on the scale
personal preference uh there was no
personal preference um but we're not
linguists so I won't say that we did it
perfectly either we just sort of well it
seems sort of reasonable that the the
differences here are sort of my there's
also like which you know what what body
of words do you use um your Corpus is
that what I call a corpus right a corpus
should it be just like the dictionary
words or should it be the words as
they're used in ordinary English
language because it's different if
you're making sentences if you're
writing a book certain letters are going
to show up more often and if you just
look at the list of words in the
dictionary that's different again but
these are all sort of minor things like
you know maybe this you know n gets one
more or not or something like ultimately
I think we did okay do you enjoy playing
the game do you play it much um as with
many of the things I actually enjoy
making the stuff more than solving the
puzzles but you know it's a fun thing to
have
around next one so this really is sort
of more of a puzzle of what it's for so
I want to give you a chance to think
about it this video continues with part
two an even more ingenious dice to
admire there's a link in the description
but if you like dice well there are
plenty of courses and puzzles over at
brilliant that are going to scratch that
itch for example just take a look at
some of
these brilliant of course is today's
episode sponsor it's full to the brim
with Great Courses and quizzes all sorts
of riddles that are going to take you
deep into the world of mathematics
computer science and other science
subjects one of the great things about
brilliant content is that it's really
interactive but it's not like a you must
get this right kind of thing it's more
engaging fun playful it's the way
learning should be and there's always
new stuff being added to their huge
collection if you want to check them out
there's a free 30-day trial and number
five viewers can get a 20% discount on
their subscription by going to
brilliant.org number file you can also
give people a subscription as a gift a
thoughtful present for that inquiry mind
in your family perhaps have a look
there'll be a link in the description
and good luck with all those puzzles
about
dice if you're interested in any of the
dice you saw in today's video you can
buy them actually I'll put a link in the
description you can find out more stuff
I'll also put links to other dice videos
we've done in the past Psy psychological
and sociological setting suppose that
you think you can control the dice of
course you're not perfect at of